Instead of grinding the thousands and thousands
and thousands of hours
that I did streaming.
And, I'm dead.
I'm going to break everything down for you guys
in the next 30 days.
Let's go.
Oh, my goodness.
The precision, the aim, the accuracy, baby!
I am Tyler Blevins.
You may know me as Ninja.
This class is about
building and establishing
a streaming presence, whether
you are a gamer or a non-gamer.
Let's go, baby!
I have cracked the code, truly,
on how to build a community,
engage with your
audience, and make
you the best possible
streamer that you can be.
You're going to learn to set
up and launch your stream,
develop your style,
build a brand,
and make your stream as
professional as possible.
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to my YouTube channel.
You'll be learning alongside
people from all over the world,
and you're going
to be able to share
your streams and this journey
alongside the community
of MasterClass.
When you're starting out, try
to have the viewer list open
at all times so that if you
see a brand new person come in,
you can just say, "Hey,
welcome to the stream.
Thank you so much
for stopping in."
And, that might encourage
that person to talk to you
and actually engage in the
chat, and you might have earned
your first follower for life.
The two months in a
row, welcome back, man.
Bobby-san, what's up, man?
How you doing?
What do I love most
about streaming?
It's so much fun.
You can bring so much
joy to other people.
And of course, obviously,
if you do everything right,
it can be very
lucrative, as well.
I started out in my
mom's basement streaming,
working at a fast food
restaurant, going to college.
And then I broke the
record for the most viewers
in a stream, the most
subscriptions, the fastest
growing YouTube
channel in the world.
Can you get some subs out here?
We out here making money.
Streaming is a place where
you can just express yourself.
This is my life.
I absolutely love it, and
I'm happy to share everything
that I've learned.
If I can do this,
anyone can do this.
I'm Ninja, and this
is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]